what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel has been making some pretty
big changes to the MCU and now fans are
very excited about this because they
want to see an increase in quality with
movies and shows in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe well guess what that is exactly
what we are about to get and now Marvel
Studios has a new plan when it comes to
the MCU which fans should get really
really excited about and now we know
some details about this plan not just
the fact that Marvel wants to improve
but now we know how exactly they're
going to go about that we already knew
that they were going to be making
changes but today we talk about how and
what they are going to be doing and yes
for those asking some delays are going
to be coming too but now we know what to
expect from Marvel as far as how many
movies and shows they'll be releasing
per year it's definitely not like what
they were doing before with phase four
in which to be fair was a ton it would
be insane mainly hard for Marvel Studios
to continue to produce four to five to
six Disney Plus shows a year and four
movies a year to keep the quality up for
all of those just doesn't seem possible
but we're gonna break down exactly how
many movies per year they're going to do
and Disney Plus shows as well as talk
about how they are restructuring their
company and restructuring the schedule
so if you love Marvel be sure to
subscribe to the channel to stay up to
date also if you subscribe and comment
on our videos you enter our giveaway
where you have a chance to win a PS5 and
Xbox series X to Marvel Legends gear and
other stuff as well Winner's Choice we
announced the winner at the end of each
month so I think one of the biggest wins
for Marvel fans is that Marvel and
Disney actually listen to the fans and
we have two people from these companies
that really do care about the MCU Marvel
Studios president Kevin foggy of course
and Disney CEO Bob Iger they have heard
the fans complained about the quality in
phase four and they both stated that
they are now going to focus on quality
over quantity and they're going to
reduce the output and con content that
they are going to be producing per year
and this is coming directly from both of
them now many fans will be excited to
hear that their new plan is pretty much
gonna be their old plan let's kind of be
honest here phase four was kind of a
test and it was also kind of a reboot
not necessarily a true reboot but a new
start for a new saga of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe some old characters
but a lot of new characters as well and
don't get me wrong we got a lot of great
things from phase four but a lot of fans
had some complaints and then we had a
lot of complaints about Ant-Man and the
wasp condominia and Marvel listened and
now they're changing and definitely for
the better so what exactly is Marvel's
new plan what are they going to be doing
we have a new report from Insider Jeff
Snyder who confirms basically what a lot
of people thought that Marvel Studios
was going to do when Kevin feige and Bob
Iger announced that they're going to
reduce the output of their content and
basically Marvel Studios is going to go
from having five to six Disney Plus
shows special presentations to only
about two per year now I'm assuming this
is just Disney Plus shows I'm assuming
there are going to be other things like
special presentations involved so two
shows a year but then of course we
should have a Halloween special a
holiday special and maybe something in
between like Silver Surfer special a
Nova special or whatever else they have
coming up the pipeline so this is a
really big change imagine trying to
produce four full Disney Plus shows each
year and then on top of that your
Halloween specials your holiday specials
and any other special that might come
out like the I am group one that's a lot
Plus on top of that you have your movies
as well now Marvel was currently for
phase four doing three to four movies a
year but now according to the same
report they're going to cut back to
doing just three a year so no more
trying to aim for four movies that is a
lot movies take a lot to make and this
is a very drastic change the full report
from Jeff Snyder States Marvel's Target
output has been reduced I don't know if
this has been reported or if this was a
line in the trades or whatever but I'm
told that the target output has reduced
from four shows to four movies a year to
two shows and three movies a year and of
course it's malleable you could get on
either side of that or whatever and I do
think this is the right move and Kevin
feige even thinks this is the right move
himself he did say I do think one of the
powerful aspects of being at Marvel
Studios is having these films and shows
hit the Zeitgeist it is harder to hit
the Zeitgeist when there's so much
product out there and so much content as
they say which is a word that I hate and
he said that as he laughed now
unfortunately this will ultimately lead
to some delays and we're already kind of
getting those everything was already
kind of delayed but now we have an
official release date for secret
Invasion however we don't have one for
Loki or any of the other upcoming Disney
Plus shows so so as we've been
experiencing you should expect some
restructuring of the phases that have
already been revealed specifically phase
five since most of phase six hasn't been
revealed yet and we've already got some
delays for physics as well with the
Fantastic Four and unless Marvel had
some shows coming out that were kind of
irrelevant to the story plot of the Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars in the entire
Multiverse Saga as well we might be
seeing some delays in the King Dynasty
and Secret Wars right now for 2024 2025
and 2026 Marvel Studios has four movies
scheduled for each of those years and if
we're only doing three now that most
likely is going to push Marvel Studios
as Phase 5 and phase six late back at
least a year and that's not counting any
Disney Plus shows that have to be pushed
back as well so we could be looking at
unfortunately a one to two year delay
however I definitely think it's worth it
if it's going to make all of these
projects a lot better but this is what
their goal is which we should be excited
about and even a recent report from the
cosmic server dot com explains that this
is the reason why we are getting these
delays according to the report they say
the delays are due to Marvel Studios
wanting to maintain a certain quality in
its films and mainly wanting to
prioritize making the films and series
the right way instead of pushing them
out prematurely which we have seen
happen but this isn't the only
restructuring that Marvel Studios is
going through right now most of you have
heard that they have fired some
Executives from Marvel Studios who had
been there a very long time Ike prometer
was recently fired and he is somebody
who very much clashed with Kevin feige
and even tried to get him fired he
actually was going to fire him except
Bob Iger stepped in and said no and
thank goodness for that because the MCU
would not be what it is without Kevin
feige Victoria Alonso was also fired
from Marvel Studios however this had a
lot of different elements to it and
wasn't just due to the fact that they
want to restructure however it was
partly that Victoria Alonso looked up
over all of the VFX Department which has
definitely been slacking lately and
people have been coming out from the
visual effects Department stating that
the work conditions were not good they
were being overworked underpaid and
weren't exactly being treated right by
Victoria Alonso and one of the biggest
restructurings that we have so far that
recently happened is the firing of the
original Fantastic Four Riders and
hiring of a new rider for the Fantastic
Four a lot of changes have happened with
the Fantastic Four lately and if you
want to hear about those you can check
out the video I did yesterday on it but
Marvel Studios did get a new rider for
the Fantastic Four and obviously this is
due to the fact that they didn't really
like the current script that they had at
the time and it's sad but it's also
extremely good news because Marvel
Studios saw that the quality was lacking
and they decided they're not going to
stand for that they're not going to
produce things that don't have high
quality so they made an adjustment to
make it better and that's exactly what
they're doing with the entirety of Base
5 and Phase 6 and simply the studio in
general so I think this is actually
actually a good plan this is basically
going back to what phase one through
three were except we're adding a few
Disney Plus shows in special
presentations I think this is a win
because we still get more content than
we're used to with phase one through
three even if we aren't getting as much
content as we got with phase four we are
still going to be getting more than
we're used to and the quality of this
content should be much better than we
got with phase 4. so that's Marvel's new
plan go ahead and let us know all of
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below do you like it do you not
like it let us know also don't forget to
like the video and again subscribe so
you can stay up to date and enter our
giveaway you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof